that said you popularize the asymptotic
notation for describing running time
obviously in the analysis of algorithms
worst cases such as such an important
part do you see any aspects of that kind
of analysis is lacking so and notation
too well the main purpose you have
notations that that help us for the
problems we want to solve and so that
they match our they match our intuitions
and people who worked in number theory
had used asymptotic notation in what
Ennis in a certain way but it was only
known to a small group of people and and
I realized that in fact it was very
useful to be able to have a notation for
something that we don't know exactly
what it is but we only know partial
about it and so on stick so for example
instead of Big O notation let's just
let's just take us a much simpler
notation where I say 0 or 1 or 0 1 or 2
and suppose that suppose that when I had
been in high school we would be allowed
to put in the middle of our formula x +
0 1 or 2 equals y ok and then then we
would learn how to multiply two such
expressions together and and you know
deal with them
well the same thing Big O notation says
here's something that's I'm not sure
what it is but I know it's not too big I
know it's not bigger than some constant
times N squared or something like that
pain so so I write Big O of N squared
and now I learned how to add Big O of N
squared to Big O of n cubed and I know I
add Big O of N squared to plus 1 and
square that and how to take logarithm
the exponential so have big O's in the
middle of them and that turned out to be
hugely valuable in all of the work that
I was trying to do is I'm trying to
figure out how good out
you